un peu partout au pays des chercheurs
sont en train de déployer un réseau de
forêt intelligente il collige une foule
de données en temps réel leur objectif
c'est d'arriver à mieux comprendre
comment les forêts vont réagir aux
changements climatiques
sonde câble chauffant d'andreu m caméra
cette forêt située au nord de montréal
est ce qu'on appelle une forêt
intelligente nicolas bélanger et son
équipe ils mesurent en continu une série
de processus écologiques ce qu'on a
tenté de faire ici en fait c'est de
simuler ou d'imiter les changements
climatiques en réchauffant les seuls en
réchauffant les soldes environ 3 ou 4
degrés celsius par rapport aux
conditions normales dans les parcelles
expérimentales des câbles chauffants
sont enfouis à une dizaine de
centimètres de profondeur
on y mesure l'attention hydriques la
force qu'exercent les racines pour
prélever l'eau donc c'est un indicateur
très important qui nous permet justement
d'évaluer notamment le stress hydrique
potentiels liés aux changements
climatiques
son collègue 8 vérifie si la hausse de
température fait grimper le flux de
carbone émis par le sol en d'autres mots
si la respiration du système racinaire
et des micro-organismes présents dans le
sol renvoie davantage de dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère
on utilise deux chambres a fallu qu'on
pose sur des cales et donc dans le fond
ce qu'on veut chercher à faire c'est
emmagasiner les co2 qui est émis par le
sol sur une période de temps donnée et
on prend plusieurs mesures à différentes
intervalle de temps pour pouvoir estimer
ce film puis ce qu'on constate en fait
c'est qu'effectivement il ya pas mal de
saut du lit et me parlera par lawson
plus loin on mime les changements
climatiques pour évaluer la tolérance
des espèces typiques de la forêt
tempérée
chaque petit drapeau représente un
érable de provenances différentes
c'est à dire que on va aller chercher
des espèces sur un gradient nos reçues
de différentes localités gradient qui va
de des états unis jusqu'à ici dans les
places et de chauffer olivier blard
caisse constate que la mortalité des
semis est plus grande et les érables
plus nordique supporte mal le
réchauffement climatique
des relevés floristiques révèle aussi
que la bio diversité diminue de manière
importante des centaines de pochette
remplie de feuilles sont aussi déposer
dans les parcelles chauffer et non
chauffé les chercheurs testent quatre
espèces érables à sucre d'érable rouge
être à grandes feuilles et peupliers à
grandes dents il note la vitesse de
décomposition de cette litière de
feuilles
c'est important parce que si si la
litière se dégrade pas ben on va voir
des changements au niveau des propriétés
mécaniques des sols et puis au niveau
des propriétés chimiques physiques qui
vont éventuellement aussi jouer sur la
germination
christophe foreuse papa suis fait le
bilan hydrique des arbres et évaluent
leur croissance dans cette parcelle
il suit une quarantaine d'érable 24
heures par jour pendant toute l'année
il mesure notamment le flux de sève
brute c'est à dire l'eau et les minéraux
puiser dans le sol par les racines et
pomper du bas vers le haut des arbres
par la transpiration
le chercheur utilise une capsule de sève
muni de trois sondes dont l'une chauffe
l'arbre aux cinq minutes
la dissipation de la chaleur permet de
suivre le déplacement de la sève brute
alors là on va mettre ça dans les troncs
et on va mais aurait un différend
profondeur comment cette salle est qu'on
va qu'on va donner va propagaient dans
les bois
le différentiel de température entre la
sonde chauffantes et les deux autres
sondes détermine la quantité d'eau qui
transitent à travers la tige de l'arbre
ces données permet de connaître la
sensibilité de chaque espèce au stress
hydrique mettons il ya des arbres qui
transpire beaucoup sans trop réfléchi
qu'est ce qui va arriver demain et il ya
des arbres qui sont un peuple
conservateur et mettons dément avoir une
sécheresse devait très préparé ne pas
être transférées qu'entre membres
transpire au subi un stress hydrique des
mouvements doux font rétrécir le tronc
et provoque des micros variations radial
tout au long de la journée
ces appareils d d'andreu m détecte ces
variations ces mesures permet aussi
d'évaluer l'impact du changement
climatique sur la croissance et la
période de croissance des arbres et de
transposer les données à l'échelle du
paysage
cette forêt niché dans les laurentides
devrait donc éventuellement lever le
voile sur bien des mystères et elle fait
partie d'un réseau d'une quarantaine de
forêt intelligente
le réseau smart fort reste créé par
banny chat au bien comprendre commandes
forêt va affecter une solution a besoin
de maintenir et son ensemble de france à
travers le canada
grâce à ce réseau le chercheur pourra
suivre ce qui se passe sur le terrain
pendant dix ans et ces données seront
d'autant plus intéressante qu'elle
seront représentatives de tous les
écosystèmes forestiers du pays dans
l'ouest canadien
ils disent que le papier four 30 est
très vulnérable sécheresse dans l'est au
québec on discute des espaces qui tantôt
sécheresse
si on travaille juste à nos qualités on
n'est pas capable dé partager ses
trouvailles et comprend où quelque chose
change quoi ça change
la quantité colossale d'informations
recueillies grâce à ce réseau de forêt
intelligente servira à développer des
modèles prévisionnels de croissance des
forêts l'industrie forestière et les
gouvernements pourront adapter leurs
stratégies sylvicoles en conséquence
[Musique]
à 5000 km de montréal dans les
territoires du nord-ouest
la forêt boréale s'étend à perte de vue
sur d'immenses superficie huit cent dix
mille kilomètres carrés et elle est en
plein bouleversement
les changements climatiques dans ce coin
du pays sont quatre fois plus rapide
qu'ailleurs sur la planète
[Musique]
au nord du 61ème parallèle se cachent
d'ailleurs un véritable laboratoire
vivant la station de recherche de scor
et quick
des scientifiques se relaient sur place
de mars à septembre courant documenter
les conséquences les changements se
déroule sous nos yeux depuis 2018 je
vois le sol s'affaisser davantage et on
observe un phénomène baptisé forêt yves
des épinettes sont de plus en plus
incliné
au cours des dernières années les
chercheurs raciste en quelque sorte un
processus de déforestation naturel les
forêts deviennent des milieux humides
formule de tourbières connectées les
unes aux autres
la forêt poussent sur un lit tourbe qui
repose sur le pergélisol julie de tourbe
d'être ici ça fesse et devient marécages
le pergélisol discontinue sur lequel
reposent les racines des arbres est
recouvert d'une couche active qui gel et
dégel selon les saisons
le pergélisol se trouve sous cette
couche est dans la région il est
relativement max le pergélisol c'est
comme le ciment qui forment la cise la
forêt boréale dans le territoire du nord
ouest avec le réchauffement
lucie m'en prend de moins en moins bien
les arbres se retrouve fragilisé les
arbres suivent ces mouvements de gel et
de dégel des gels s'accentue plus les
arbres bouge c'est une forme de danse
que les arbres font pour s'adapter et
survivre qui m'a
le réchauffement accroît aussi la
décomposition de la matière organique ce
qui libère du gaz carbonique et du
méthane dans l'atmosphère à scotty creek
les chercheurs mesurent donc
rigoureusement le flux de carbone et
l'épaisseur de la couche active
recouvrant le pergélisol
on espère une personne assise gratuit
dans le sol jusqu'à ce qu'on sente une
résistance l'historique des mesures nous
permet de constater que la couche active
des gels de plus en plus l'hydrologie se
transforme également les marécages ne
retiennent plus l'eau l'écoulement sous
terre un change et le niveau d'eau
grimpe au point de faire augmenter le
débit de la rivière lee young un
affluent du fleuve mackenzie le long des
berges et on voit de plus en plus
d'arbres tombés dans la rivière
des membres des premières nations des
shows sont partenaires du programme de
recherche à scotty quick ses gardiens de
la forêt ont le mandat de documenter les
changements qu'ils observent forêt ivre
qui dépérissent et d'eauze sat inquiète
pourquoi parce que ça risque d'avoir un
impact énorme sur la faune des forêts
c'est leur habitat leur refuge dans les
territoires-du-nord-ouest la forêt
boréale est profondément ancré dans le
mode de vie des habitants
les conséquences de réchauffement risque
donc d'être dramatique à yellowknife
la biologiste suzanne carrière
inventorie les impacts possibles du
réchauffement sur la forme il ya des
changements sont surtout les animaux de
la taïga où on est
les grands cycles fait de déclin et de
remonter des populations sont typiques
de cette écosystèmes nordiques mais avec
les changements climatiques les cycles
sont modifiées et des phénomènes
nouveaux surviennent on voit de plus en
plus de caribous de femelles qui vont
mourir en plein été on peut avoir des
grosses canicule dans la taïga les
boeufs musqués eux des habitués de la
toundra se déplacent de plus en plus
vers les forêts du sud des espèces
montrent aussi une à une vers le nord le
cerf de virginie entre autres ces
changements modifient peu à peu
l'écosystème forestier jeu au désert des
problèmes phytosanitaires de plus en
plus aigus sont aussi observées à partir
des inventaires aériens qu'il réalise
pour le gouvernement
dzeko bolsens qui produit chaque année
un bilan de santé de la forêt les dégâts
causés par la tordeuse des bourgeons de
l'épinette l'inquiète la tordeuse des
bourgeons de l'épinette a toujours été
présente ici mais on voit maintenant de
grandes infestation monter toujours plus
haut n'aura même au delà du cercle
polaire de vastes peuplement de trembles
sont aussi en déclin victimes
d'événements extrêmes comme des
inondations ou des sécheresses répétées
ou durement frappées par des épidémies
anormalement longue 2009 serpentine du
tremble
ces perturbations n'augure rien de bon
pour l'industrie forestière des
territoires du nord ouest principalement
constitué de petites entreprises de
sciage dans la région des carmes au news
dans le sud
les promoteurs voit grand mais il risque
d'être confronté aux conséquences du
réchauffement limes et forestiers les
plus productifs sont dans des endroits
difficilement accessibles
on ne put les récoltes etc en hiver et
les hivers sont de plus en plus qu'aux
feux de forêt épidémies d'insectes une
succession de perturbations naturelles a
façonné la forêt boréale et dans les
territoires du nord-ouest le
réchauffement prononcé et rapide rend la
forêt plus fragile et vulnérable cette
forêt est unique au canada et dans le
monde
j'espère qu'il saura se défendre face
aux changements climatiques
[Musique]
et les transformations que les
chercheurs observent dans cet écosystème
nordiques sont cruciales pour comprendre
ce qui viendra éventuellement plus au
sud
[Musique]
des chercheurs ontariens collabore aussi
à des travaux menés sur un site de
recherche spectaculaire au coeur de la
forêt du minnesota on l'appelle le
sponsor project et c'est une véritable
machine à avancer dans le temps akram
rapide à l'ouest du lac supérieur une
dizaine de massifs forestiers sont
recouverts d'immenses dôme de verre il
abrite des arbres de 40 et 50 ans des
arbustes des plans et des tourbières
dans les coupoles témoins la végétation
est soumise aux conditions actuelles
dans les autres ont reproduit les
conditions climatiques anticipées d'ici
2100 à l'intérieur de ce dôme on
retrouve la température la plus élevée
soit 9 degrés celsius de plus que la
température ambiante
les changements sont déjà bien réelle
dans les dombes chauffé par exemple la
croissance des épinettes noires ralenti
et les effets sont particulièrement
dramatiques
là où la température est la plus élevée
des arbres souffrent les mélèzes mais
surtout les épinettes noires elles
dépérissent
certaines sont même morte les arbustes e
s'adapte très bien et prolifèrent tandis
que les tourbières d'importants pièges à
carbone ça sèche les chercheurs mesurent
d'ailleurs des niveaux de co2 et de
méthane
inquiétant à l'intérieur des dogmes les
plus chauds fait ce projet de recherche
n'en est qu'à ses débuts et se
poursuivra encore jusqu'en 2035